[Música]
[Aplausos]
sabían ustedes
que del 25 al 29 por ciento de la
población a nivel mundial padece de
algún tipo de dolor
esto significa que alrededor de 2000
millones de personas en el mundo sufren
de alguna clase de dolor basada en estas
estadísticas les pregunto creen ustedes
que el dolor puede ser su amigo
probablemente la mayoría responderá que
no al verme pensar en ella viene a
hablarnos del dolor sin ni siquiera
parece que lo sufre pero se equivocan yo
formo parte de ese porcentaje de la
población
por más de 6 años sufrí de dolores
severos en mi columna que me llevaron a
someterme a una cirugía mayor al
despertar
lo primero que descubrí era que el dolor
a pesar que había disminuido estaba
dispuesto a quedarse
esto provocó en mí que sintiera que le
era amenazante y que entraba a mi vida
de una forma inesperada qué sucede
yo en el momento lo consideremos intruso
pero sin embargo él me estaba dando la
primera lección de vida no bien
aprendida no somos autosuficientes
siempre necesitamos de otros incluso
para llegar a este mundo
esta situación me llevó a pensar
pasen un largo periodo en cama
acompañada de mi familia pero tratando
de identificar a este intruso que me
llevaba de la mano por un viaje hacia mi
interior haciéndome descubrir área de mí
que desconocía imagínense empecé a
disfrutar de mi compañía y sobre todo a
querer esta nueva verónica esto al final
me condujo a una experiencia reveladora
y enriquecedora por lo que siempre le
estaré agradecido también el dolor me
mostró cuántas personas se preocupaban y
me amaban a pesar que en un inicio yo
los había rechazado
y también me ayudó a obtener
herramientas que yo pensé que no tenía y
que sin su ayuda
jamás hubiera descubierto segunda
lección de vida
pero que fue lo más impactante
el dolor penetró en mi vida de una forma
dramática interfirió mi normal
desenvolvimiento y se volvió altamente
incapacitante
esto que provocó que yo reflexionar
y pensarán estamos los seres humanos
preparados
para soportar los distintos tipos de
dolor
después de lo vivido considero que nos
porque porque el ser humano nunca nunca
está preparado para que su vida se
interrumpa de la manera como se
interrumpió la mía entonces esto me
llevó a pensar también usted dirán pero
si fue un viaje hacia mi interior
descubriendo cosas y haciéndome
preguntas y me llevó a pensar
ustedes saben cuántos tipos de dolor
cuantas caras puede tener el dolor
entonces pienso que debo explicarles
algunas y así estarán preparados para
identificarlo y darle la bienvenida como
a un maestro y no considerarlo un
enemigo el dolor tiene muchas
clasificaciones el dolor según su
intensidad puede ser leve moderado y
severo según su duración puede ser agudo
crónico agudos y dura menos de tres
meses crónico si sobrepasa este tiempo
imagínense esta estadística que les voy
a decir el 20 por ciento de la población
a nivel mundial sufre de dolor crónico
que es el que generalmente viene
acompañado de componentes psicológicos
en mi caso fue la ansiedad
que constantemente me decía que ciertas
partes de mi cuerpo ya no funcionaban
como antes y no lo volverían a hacer
esto provocó en mí una depresión pero el
dolor estaba ahí y me dijo esto no es el
fin del mundo
con esto no termina tu vida porque
porque me acompañó para decirme me
permite levantarme todos los días
puedo caminar incluso en forma coqueta
y les gustó incluso bailar y eso me
encanta y por eso estoy agradecida con
dios pero el dolor también me mostró sus
rostros sus otros rostros no solo eso es
muy bonito me mostró el físico y el
emocional el físico lo sentí en cada
parte de mi cuerpo especialmente en los
primeros días posteriores a la cirugía
qué pasaba mi médico me decía tranquila
esto lo vamos a superar juntos
pero yo pensaba no creo que es así
porque si es fuera así él estuviera
conmigo gritando en mitad de la noche
cuando el dolor severo me atacaba
y ahí los que estaban siempre a mi lado
era mi familia hasta me cantaba mi
esposo para tratar de aplacar porque en
ese momento usted lo que quiere es como
salir corriendo cuando el dolor es tan
intenso
pero al final
logré sobreponerme el dolor me mostró
también que yo tenía la capacidad para
superar eso y salir airosa de esta
situación
quizás el rostro con el que yo más me
identifique fue con la emocional porque
el emocional me hizo reconocer que había
situaciones que yo no podía manejar
que no podía controlar ese aspecto y eso
fue una gran revelación para mí porque
porque al final todos queremos tener
todo bajo un solo paraguas y que no pase
nada pero el dolor les voy a decir
sinceramente cuando el dolor penetro en
mi vida de verdad que es un antes y un
después pero no fue el fin del mundo
qué paso adicional bueno los seres
humanos
nunca pero nunca estamos preparados para
enfrentarlo
yo tuve que admitir que me costó mucho
acoplarme a mi nueva condición física
limitada eso me llevó
a darme cuenta que existían barreras de
accesibilidad
que la verdad nunca había notado y
sinceramente voy a hablar con la verdad
tampoco me importaba
usted no sabe lo difícil que fue
descubrir no poder entrar un restaurante
porque no tiene una rampa
yo o mi tía lugares aunque me encantaban
pero no estaban adecuados para personas
con discapacidad
me volví exigente y beligerante a la
hora de luchar por mis derechos
pero lo más importante fue la
transformación interior
que me llevo a ser más solidaria y
empática con las personas que de ahora
en adelante serían mis compañeros de
vida
desde entonces experimentó una gran
satisfacción
al poner mi granito de arena diario
en la lucha nuestra porque es la lucha
nuestra luchar porque nuestros derechos
de discapacidad sean reconocidos esto
también me llevo a una reflexión
la fragilidad de mi existencia
y como todo en un minuto puede cambiar
yo pase de ser activa
a tener una condición física limitada
pero eso no me freno
no me ven que estoy aquí o sea que no me
frena entonces al final yo les voy a
comprender lo que ha pasado en mi vida
primero pasé de ser una persona digamos
entre paréntesis normal entre comillas
porque ahora soy normal es más creo que
el dolor esa parte se la voy a decir de
gratis el dolor ahora me puso más en
forma
porque si ustedes me hubieran visto hace
un año se verán esto
extrañado como me dijo mi neurocirujano
me dijo si usted viera ha sido un
poquito más delgada o si usted no
estuviera tan sobrepeso
yo le dije dígamelo obesa y mórbida o
que las dos cosas entonces quizás todas
esas complicaciones que no voy a entrar
a detallar pero que fueron únicas dicen
que cuando el área médica entra a una
cirugía todo el malo le pasa bueno eso
pasó en mi caso yo le voy a decir algo
yo he enfrentado al dolor a lo largo de
mi vida en mis pacientes lo he visto en
todas sus manifestaciones pero yo nunca
estuve preparada para realmente
experimentarlo ahora yo puedo comprender
más a mis pacientes pero el dolor no
sólo se quedó ahí el dolor me mostró un
sinnúmero de personas que fueron mi
apoyo en el momento en que yo pensé que
no podía ganar la batalla porque ellos
sí confiaban que yo podía hacerlo hoy y
no se equivocaron estaban en lo cierto
la gane
hoy les puedo decir que cuento con un
amigo porque porque él me llevo a que mi
instinto de supervivencia
yo pudiera salir adelante y tuve que
encontrar una manera saludable de lidiar
con mi dolor
entonces quiero decirles que al final
yo tengo
un amigo
que me sustenta
que me acompaña que está todos los días
conmigo está aquí
y ese amigo me acompaña en lo físico
emocional y psicológico convirtiéndome
en un ser humano fortalecido que no se
amilana que está dispuesto a enfrentar
los retos que cada día atrae
con un propósito claro
ser testimonio viviente de cómo el dolor
pudo cambiar mi vida pero de una forma
radical y positiva que el nombre
destruyó si no me reconstruyó y aquí
estoy
en noviembre de este año
en la basílica del monte montserrat a
más de 3100 pies de actitud
y pude ir y estoy con todos mis seres
queridos y con mis grandes amigos
entonces al final les dejo este mensaje
y esta frase que en la que me sustenta
en los momentos en que siento que las
fuerzas me pueden fallar
nunca sabrás
cuán fuerte eres hasta que serlo sea tu
única opción gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]